[Música]
Quién dice que en las dictaduras nunca
hay elecciones se equivoca queréis un
ejemplo pues este pasado domingo 3 de
diciembre los venezolanos Aunque todavía
no pueden elegir libremente su gobierno
fueron llamados a votar en un referéndum
sobre una supuesta causa común la Guyana
es equiva Venezuela sostiene desde hace
más de 100 años una disputa territorial
con Guyana El pequeño país vecino que en
los últimos años ha hecho grandes
descubrimientos de petróleo está en
discusión la soberanía de
15954 km lo que representa el 74,2 1%
del territorio guyanés y para fijar su
posición el gobierno venezolano organizó
un referéndum el resultado por supuesto
era previsible el 90 por apoyó la tesis
que ahora defiende el gobierno chavista
esto es intentar recuperar la Guyana
esequiva qué
esperabais a pesar de ser una disputa
que viene ya de muy lejos en los últimos
meses el gobierno chavista ha llevado a
cabo una escalada como hacía mucho
tiempo no se veía sobre este tema la
tensión está el rojo vivo y ojo porque
no hablamos de una apelación judicial ni
nada por el estilo sino de Auténticos
tambores de guerra maduro desempolva el
reclamo sobre la soberanía Venezolana en
la guayana seiva Lula quiere evitar una
guerra entre Venezuela y Guyana y manda
a un hombre de confianza a mediar
queridos amigos amigas así están las
cosas
según el gobierno algo más de 10
millones de venezolanos acudieron a
votar de los cuales más del 90 por
votaron a favor de la reivindicación
territorial del esequivo que está
llevando a cabo el gobierno el aparato
del Estado promocionó la votación Con
vallas conciertos merchandising
concentraciones militares y un montón de
publicidad en redes sociales pero pese a
todo la cifra resulta difícil de creer
los colegios estuvieron prácticamente
vacíos Pero esto amigos es Venezuela sea
como sea ahora el régimen chavista tiene
un nuevo comodín bajo el
brazo El caso es que toda esta
sorprendente tensión que ahora se ha
desatado repentinamente en torno a la
relación guyanesa venezolana nos lleva a
hacernos varias preguntas qué pretende
exactamente el régimen chavista con este
referéndum por qué tanto interés de
repente por esta cuestión Cómo de
probable es que pueda estallar un
conflicto armado en el esequivo Pues
todo esto y más lo vamos a ver a
continuación gasolina y arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
para entender cómo y cuándo nace este
conflicto tenemos que remontarnos hasta
la era de las colonias concretamente
cuando Guyana estaba bajo el control del
imperio británico y Venezuela bajo el
control del imperio español La Guyana
esquiba formaba parte de la capitanía
general de Venezuela un dominio español
creado por Carlos io en el año
1777 sin embargo la primera intromisión
en la zona no fue británica Sino
holandesa fueron los neerlandeses los
que ante la falta de control efectivo de
Madrid plantaron las primeras colonias
no españolas en la
región sin embargo tras una serie de
guerras y enfrentamientos los holandeses
muy debilitados Perdieron el control de
sus asentamientos y los británicos se
convirtieron en los gobernadores de
facto en
1796 Poco después el tratado
anglo-holandesa
de Viena en 1800 los 15 dieron como
resultado que las colonias de esequivo
de merara y berbice fueron cedidas
oficialmente al Reino Unido así nació la
guayana británica que colindaba en el
oeste con la recién nacida Venezuela
además en paralelo a la posesión
británica de Guyana Caracas logró su
independencia de España El problema es
que los límites entre ambos territorios
no estaban nada claros por eso en 1841
la Royal geographical society contrató a
Robert herman schomburg un naturalista
alemán para que trazara las fronteras de
la Guyana británica tanto con Venezuela
en su parte oeste como con la Guyana
neerlandesa hoy surinam en el este este
estudio terminó Estableciendo la
conocida como Lía shbg una frontera que
efectivamente le dio 80.000 km cuadrad
adicionales a la guayana británica
pensad que antes de la determinación de
esta línea era el río esequivo la
frontera natural entre ambos
territorios Pues bien es precisamente
este tramo el que podemos encar entre el
río esquivo y la línea scur lo que hoy
ha disparado la tensión política e
incluso militar entre Georg Town y
Caracas y la pregunta es por qué nunca
se ha logrado alcanzar una solución de
verdad que en 170 años nunca se ha
logrado aclarar la situación de la zona
En qué se basa ahora el chavismo para
lanzar una reivindicación tan agresiva
pues queridos amigos amigas para
entenderlo tenemos que dar un pequeño
repaso a los libros de historia
atentos de las trampas judiciales
escenario
bélico tras sellar su independencia en
1821 y con la muerte de Simón Bolívar
hacia 1830 Venezuela entró en una
espiral de violencia interna cuando
varios caudillos locales buscaron
hacerse con el control del país Pues
bien fue justo en ese momento cuando se
dibujó la línea schomburg de tal forma
que cuando luego las cosas se calmaron
en Caracas El dominio británico al oeste
del esquivo ya era un hecho hacia 1880
el entonces presidente venezolano
Antonio Guzman blanco comenzó a
denunciar a nivel internacional la
intromisión británica hasta el punto de
que en 1895 el tema se coló en la
mismísima agenda de la Casa Blanca la
disputa ha llegado a una etapa tal que
hace que ahora incumba a los Estados
Unidos tomar medidas para determinar con
suficiente certeza Cuál es la verdadera
línea divisoria entre la República de
Venezuela y la guayana británica el
mensaje del presidente norteamericano
obligó a Londres a tener que aceptar un
laudo arbitral internacional y en
febrero de
1897 Venezuela Estados Unidos y Gran
Bretaña llegaron a un acuerdo para
concretar el desarrollo de un proceso
judicial que dirimieran de una vez por
todas la disputa territorial sin embargo
la palabra acuerdo no es lo más ideal
para describir la posición
venezolana una de las reglas acordadas
por Washington y Londres contemplaba
dejar a Venezuela fuera de la
conformación del tribunal arbitral al
tiempo que la defensa del país
sudamericano en el juicio quedaría en
manos de abogados estadounidenses de
esta forma Caracas fue un mero
espectador en torno al proceso judicial
que se desarrolló en París en
1899 un juicio donde una parte no está
siquiera presente el tribunal compuesto
por dos británicos dos estadounidenses y
un Ruso como juez neutral determinó que
la línea zurg sí conformaba la frontera
real entre Venezuela y Guyana
legitimando por tanto El dominio
británico al oeste del río esequivo Eso
sí a Venezuela se le otorgó quizás como
una cierta compensación la soberanía de
las bocas del río Orinoco un enclave
estraté México Pero por supuesto mucho
más limitado que la reclamación
venezolana y la pregunta es cómo se
justificó este fallo judicial pues 100
años después Lo cierto es que aún las
cosas no están nada claras los motivos
de la resolución judicial nunca fueron
publicados y por eso desde entonces
Venezuela pues considera la ocupación
británica como una usurpación más tarde
en la década de los 50 Venezuela
experimento un importante crecimiento
económico bajo la dictadura de Marcos
Pérez Jiménez un tipo que años después
de ser derrocado hizo público que el
país sudamericano ha mantenido durante
décadas planes para recuperar
militarmente el territorio del esquivo
estamos desarrollando una labor que a mi
juicio hubiera culminado con dos cosas
o la guayana inglés en este Entonces se
anexa al territorio venezolano con un
estatus especial o la hubiéramos tenido
que por la fuerza recuperar el
territorio del
esequivo cosa no se quedó ahí en 1962
Venezuela comenzó a reclamar ante las
Naciones Unidas que se considerara nulo
el laudo arbitral de 1899 ante las
sospechas de que en la resolución se
quiso favorecer los intereses británicos
el resultado es que en
1966 Venezuela y Reino Unido aceptaron
Buscar un nuevo mecanismo que
sustituyera el laudo arbitral de París
El problema es que esto sucedió apenas
unas pocas semanas antes de que Londres
le concediera la independencia a Guyana
a a partir de ese momento las
conversaciones tendrían que ser entre
Caracas y Georgetown y claro Aunque el
acuerdo alcanzado entre Londres y
Caracas contemplaba un plazo máximo de 4
años para que las partes se pusieran de
acuerdo en el nuevo gobierno de Guyana
no querían saber nada de ese tema al
final la situación quedó estancada con
algún que otro altercado militar entre
medias pero lo cierto Es que poco a poco
este tema se fue apagando hasta ahora
cuando maduro lo ha vuelto a poner sobre
la mesa y por eso Una pregunta
importante que tenemos que hacernos
llegados hasta aquí es cómo ha sido
realmente la relación de la revolución
bolivariana con toda esta disputa
territorial Hasta qué punto este tema le
preocupó al comandante Chávez pues ojo
queridos amigos porque creo que aquí nos
vamos a llevar todos muchas
sorpresas Chávez y Guyana la luna de
miel que no
fue a ver creo que para nadie es un
secreto que Hugo Chávez supuso un antes
y un después en la historia de Venezuela
la llegada en 1998 de la Revolución
bolivariana supuso rehacer por completo
todo el sistema político venezolano Y
sabéis qué pese a su conocido discurso
antiimperialista y antioccidental desde
el comienzo de su gobierno Hugo Chávez
intentó fraternizar con su vecino
guyanés No me creéis pues fijaos ha
nacido un sentimiento de hermandad hacia
Guyana que hemos venido a fortalecer y
debo decirles que yo Sigo estudiando los
mapas de Guyana pero no para lanzar para
que vistas ni meter tanques de guerra
sino para ver por dónde va a venir la
carretera entre Venezuela y Georgetown o
para ver dónde podemos impulsar
proyectos de desarrollo conjunto de
hecho petr Caribe una alianza creada en
2005 para permitir a los países
caribeños comprar petróleo venezolano en
condiciones preferentes fue uno de los
instrumentos clave de la política
Internacional del socialismo del siglo
XXI Pues bien sabéis que Guyana fue uno
de los primeros países en sumarse a esta
iniciativa firmado acuerdo de suministro
de hidrocarburos a Guyana el convenio
suscrito en el marco del acuerdo de
cooperación energética petrocaribe
permitirá a la vecina nación recibir
gasolina diesel jeta 1 fuel oil y
asfalto según sus requerimientos el
suministro establecido representa el 50%
del consumo diario de la nación como
veis de esta forma George Town se
convirtió en energéticamente dependiente
de Caracas una posición que le daba al
gobierno venezolano una enorme
influencia el informe del Banco Central
de Guyana de 2009 registraba una deuda
de 143 millones de dólares con Venezuela
equivalentes en ese momento al 15% de la
deuda pública externa y se esperaba que
para 2010 la deuda ascendiera a 180
millones de dólares aproximadamente pero
pese a todo el tema del esequivo nunca
se puso sobre la
mesa de hecho Chávez trató a Guyana como
si ambos países fueran víctimas del
imperialismo angloamericano recuerdo que
mi primer contacto con Guyana fue en
unos planes de guerra cuando Venezuela
era había sido convertida en un sub
imperio otos nos metieron en la cabeza
hace muchos años que ustedes eran
enemigos nuestros Imagínate tú y son
hermanos fueron de hecho muchos los que
entonces denunciaron que Venezuela
estaba perdiendo una oportunidad
histórica para intentar solucionar su
vieja reivindicación territorial unas
críticas que fueron a más cuando Guyana
comenzó a buscar petróleo exploración de
crudo de Guyana reaviva polémica con
Venezuela la oposición venezolana acusó
al gobierno el miércoles de hacer caso
omiso a la exploración petrolera de
Guyana en una región fronteriza
reclamada por Venezuela y llegados hasta
aquí la gran gran pregunta es por qué
rayos Hugo Chávez no hizo nada para
intentar recuperar el esequivo pues la
cosa es que el chavismo tenía otras
prioridades sobre todo su enfrentamiento
político con
Colombia de hecho en 2009 ante la
instalación de bases norteamericanas en
territorio colombiano Chávez se atrevió
a sugerir que se podría desatar la
guerra en la región yo cumplo con mi
obligación moral como jefe de estado
presidente de Venezuela y soldado que
soy de alertar Vientos de guerra a
soplar por eso Chávez buscaba aislar
poco a poco a los países no socialistas
de la región y para lograrlo intentó
convertirse en algo así como el sugardad
del Caribe Y eso es exactamente lo que
le permitió a Guyana aprovecharse de la
ganga del petróleo venezolano al tiempo
que Caracas aparcaba su histórico
enfrentamiento irónicamente el
Ministerio de relaciones exteriores
venezolano durante toda esta etapa
estuvo a cargo del mismísimo Nicolás
Maduro que por supuesto no se alejaba un
milímetro de la estrategia del líder
precisamente por eso el tema del esquivo
solo volvió a tomar relevancia cuando en
2013 después de la muerte de Chávez
numerosas petroleras comenzaron a
confirmar la existencia de yacimientos
petroleros en la plataforma continental
de la Guyana esquiva ese a todo maduro
no fue más allá de simples protestas sin
más importancia hasta que de repente la
segunda mitad de 2023 ha estallado una
especie de fervor nacionalista en el
gobierno bolivariano y la pregunta es
por qué justo ahora qué demonios gana el
chavismo haciendo nacer esta vieja
polémica Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
jugando con
fuego queridos amigos y amigas Lo cierto
es que el interés del chavismo por
reanudar la polémica con Guyana está
lleno de interrogantes un ejemplo de
esto lo tenemos en las propias preguntas
del referéndum una consulta popular
compuesta por cinco preguntas con una
redacción más bien compleja pero en
cualquier caso de ellas son dos las que
generan mucha inquietud está usted de
acuerdo con la posición histórica de
Venezuela de no reconocer la
jurisdicción de la Corte Internacional
de Justicia para resolver la
controversia territorial sobre la
guayana esquiva está usted de acuerdo
con la creación del estado guayana
esquiva y se desarrolle un plan
acelerado para la atención integral a la
población actual y futura de ese
territorio que incluya entre otros el
otorgamiento de la ciudadanía y cédula
de identidad venezolana conforme al
acuerdo de Ginebra y el derecho
internacional incorporando en
consecuencia dicho estado en el mapa del
territorio venezolano estas dos
preguntas le dan al Estado venezolano un
mandato Popular de alto riesgo y es que
en primer lugar desconocer la Corte
Internacional de Justicia prácticamente
deja el conflicto sin solución
diplomática posible y es aquí donde
surge el segundo problema ante la
ausencia de salidas diplomáticas qué es
lo que
[Música]
queda luego se plantea la anexión
territorial del esequivo algo que por
supuesto solo podría ocurrir mediante
del uso de la fuerza que nosotros vamos
a defender nuestros derechos sobre la
guayana esquiba en todos los ámbitos la
vamos a defender sin caer en
provocaciones y sin escuchar los
tambores de la guerra que el presidente
Guyana hoy impulsado en Guyana han
saltado todas las alarmas Al fin y al
cabo lo que está en juego es el 74 por
del territorio del país así como la
inmensa mayor parte de una producción
petrolera que no deja de crecer Guyana
dice ante la Corte Internacional de
Justicia que el referéndum en Venezuela
por zona en disputa es una amenaza
existencial para los guyaneses lo que
está en juego amigos es mucho más que su
extensión territorial Y es que veréis
desde que la producción de crudo guyanés
comenzó a despegar en el año 2015 el
país está experimentando un crecimiento
casi exponencial hasta el punto de que
en pocos años podría convertirse en el
país más rico de toda Sudamérica pero un
momento queridos amigos y amigas de
visual politic no nos dejemos engañar
realmente es posible que toda esta
artimaña nacionalista sea por el
esequivo en principio esto que queréis
que os diga es algo algo muy difícil de
creer porque las contradicciones están a
plena vista Guyana ASUME una posición
beligerante de odio contra la República
bolivariana de Venezuela donde Guyana
hace pactos con la ot mó con el comando
sur de los Estados Unidos como veis
Según el propio Nicolás Maduro el
supuesto cambio de actitud de Guyana se
produjo en el año 2015 Entonces por qué
se esperaron 8 años para protestar tan
enérgicamente si esta zona tiene tanto
interés para el chavismo Por qué no int
tentaron recuperarla antes cuando las
condiciones eran más idóneas pues
atentos porque lo cierto Es que aquí hay
gato encerrado también dispuestos a
escarmentar a quien se atreva a tocar 1
metro cuadrado de territorio argentino y
quieren venir que vengan le
presentaremos batalla lo que acabáis de
ver es al dictador argentino Leopoldo
fortunato galtieri celebrando ante miles
de argentinos la recuperación de las
malvinas en la primera semana de abril
de 1982 hoy sabemos que la decisión de
ocupar las Islas bajo soberanía
británica tuvo mucho que ver con la
pérdida de legitimidad de la dictadura
Argentina digamos que la causa
territorial fue una treta para intentar
recuperar capital político y apoyo
social para así poder seguir en el poder
el resultado Pues un absoluto desastre
los británicos enviaron una fuerza de
combate que expulsó a los argentinos y
aceleró la caída de la dictadura La
pregunta es está el chavismo buscando
generar una situación
[Música]
similar Pues a priori hay varias
diferencias primero Guyana no es un
territorio británico sino una nación
independiente por lo que el conflicto no
involucraría a una potencia militar en
segundo lugar en un potencial conflicto
militar la disparidad de fuerzas es
enorme Venezuela tiene unos 137,000
efectivos por tierra mar y aire mientras
que las fuerzas armadas de Guyana apenas
reúnen cerca de 5,000 miembros a pesar
de las reconocidas limitaciones
operativas de las fuerzas armadas
venezolanas la escala de competencia Es
simplemente Irreversible para Georgetown
aunque no serían las mismas
circunstancias el objetivo del chavismo
podría ser el mismo que el de la junta
militar Argentina evitar una apertura
democrática a Costa de un conflicto
militar que enaltezca una causa
nacionalista recordad que tanto la
oposición venezolana como los Estados
Unidos están negociando con el régimen
de maduro la celebración de unas
elecciones limpias en 2024 que por
supuesto supondrían la salida del
régimen del poder por eso para muchos
analistas la situación con Guyana solo
Busca justificar un estado de emergencia
o de conmoción interna que congele este
proceso de apertura también hay quienes
creen que este pasado referéndum fue un
simulacro para engrasar la maquinaria
electoral chavista y testear las
alteraciones del voto electrónico que el
chavismo buscaría emplear para
perpetuarse en el poder y en el peor de
los casos la tensión con Guyana podría
darle a Caracas un nuevo comodín en la
negociación con
Washington
sea como sea si algo está claro es que
en toda esta historia hay un actor que
será absolutamente clave en Cómo se
sucedan los acontecimientos estamos
hablando por supuesto de las fuerzas
armadas venezolanas la cuestión es que
un estado de semig guerra o incluso un
intento de Invasión fortalecería un más
el peso de los militares en el actual
gobierno bolivariano empeñado estoy en
pedirles que salgan a votar Esta no es
una guerra armada por
ahora no es una guerra m por eso quizás
de momento el alto mando militar se ha
mostrado comprometido con el tema del
esquivo la cuestión es si a la hora de
la verdad estarían realmente dispuestos
a iniciar un conflicto armado con el
único fin de sostener un proyecto
político que se cae a pedazos quizás no
sé piensen que una intervención militar
sería corta por la incapacidad de Guyana
para defenderse sin embargo de
intentarlo lo más probable es que el
conflicto podría escalar a nivel
regional e incluso internacional Laura
Richardson general del ejército de
Estados Unidos y comandante del Comando
sur de Estados Unidos visitará Guyana
del 25 al 27 de Julio para reunirse con
la fuerza de defensa de Guyana la
Embajada de Estados Unidos y líderes de
la comunidad del Caribe para discutir la
asociación de defensa de Estados Unidos
con Guyana y los socios de caricom
vicepresidente guyanés funcionarios de
defensa de Estados Unidos visitarán
guiana en medio de disputa con Venezuela
este año la cooperación en materia de
defensa entre Georgetown y Washington ha
crecido considerablemente Y es que a ver
el hecho de que este país se esté
convirtiendo en una importante potencia
petrolera liderada precisamente por laon
Mobil es posible que tenga mucho que ver
por eso aunque en solitario gyana no
podría resistir nunca a una invasión
venezolana la probabilidad de que una
coalición internacional acudiera a su
auxilio no se puede descartar en
absoluto amigos amigas el chavismo
parece ahora dispuesto a cruzar una
línea roja sumamente preocupante
provocar una escaramuza militar en una
región donde la guerra ha brillado por
su ausencia Pero qué queréis que os diga
personalmente creo que no estamos sino
ante una nueva cortina de humo para
intentar mejorar su fuerza negociadora y
sobre todo crear el caldo de cultivo
perfecto capaz de echar a bajo cualquier
posibilidad de que se celebren
elecciones libres en 2024 sea como sea
ahora sabemos que las cartas están sobre
la mesa dicho esto turno para ti
conocías la disputa entre Venezuela y
Guyana crees que Caracas podría
atreverse a invadir a su país vecino
déjanos Como siempre tu respuesta en los
comentarios y habramos debate y ahora si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de like y
suscribiros a visual politic Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la
[Música]
próxima